- Un lundi sur deux depuis
septembre, c'est un nouveau
rituel qui se répète
dans la grande salle commune
de l'oisisisme Boyle Street.
Chandails et cotons ouatés
se transforment en canevas;
ici, on se sert du dessin et
de l'impression pour s'exprimer.
"Le premier atelier a été donné
à l'occasion de la Journée
nationale de vérité et
de réconciliation", iqiqique
la coordonnatrice du centre.
À Edmonton, la grande majorité
des itinérants sont autochtones.
Une réalité qui se raconte
désormais sur isisissu.
Pour plusieurs clients deBoBoBor
contact avec l'art depuis
qu'ils sont dans la rue.
La technique d'impression est
plutôt facile et très manuelle,
et le résultat, tangible.
Woody, un ancien menuisier,
apprécie de pouvoir travailler
de nouveau avec ses mains.
"Ça donne aux gens quelque chose
à faire et on reçoit
c c chandail", se félicite-t-i.
Mais ici, souvent, on repart
avec plus qu'un vêtement :
le programme permet d'établir
un premier contact avec
des personnes qui, autrement,
ne se laissaient pas approcher.
L'expert de l'impression,
c'est lui. TraSaSaSalty
est tatoueur et artiste.
Il pratique l'impression
depuis son adolescence.
"Une activité qui rassemble
les gens", dit-il.
Quand Travis a été approché
pouranananiser bénévolement
l'atelier, il a accepté
tout de suite. Une façon
pour lui de partager sa passion
et redonner à une communauté
opopop souvent négligée.
Une cinquantaine de chandails et
de cotons ouatés peuvent ainsi
êe e e donnés à chaque atelier.
Dans l'hiver glacial d'Edmonton,
peu de sources de chaleur
peuvent créer autant de fierté.
Ici Mathieu Gohier,
Radio-Canada, Edmonto